this episode is sponsored by ren a
website where you calculate your carbon
emissions
you can also sign up to make a monthly
contribution to offset your emissions or
support rainforest protection projects
by clicking our link in the description
[Music]
somewhere around 470 million years ago
something happened that shouldn't have
been particularly striking
an algae found its way onto land on its
own that's not an unusual event
over billions of years
many different types of algae have been
able to find their way from their fresh
or marine homes
and carve out new lives and niches they
found on land
but
something was different about this algae
something special it would take the
algae on an evolutionary journey through
millions and millions of years
changing our whole world in the process
this algae
turned the lands of this earth green
altered the chemistry of our atmosphere
and created homes for future life
this algae
would give rise to all of the land
plants that we know of today
land plants are incredibly diverse
they've had all those hundreds of
millions of years to get that way some
have trunks
some have flowers
some are low to the ground
even in a small patch of forest
the variations can seem
endless but
all of those plants belong to a single
clade called the embryophyta
they're divided into two broad
categories
there are the bryophytes which lack the
vasculature to grow tall
these include mosses and liverworts
and then there are the tracheophytes
which do have vascular tissues that
carry water and support their growth
these are you know they're just about
everything else
trees flowers that plant climbing up the
corner of your room
all land plants are descended from an
ancient member of a group that's still
around called the streptophyte algae
but what was so special about this algae
what enabled it to cultivate lands and
take them over to an extent
that no other algae could
we don't know
it's a fundamental mystery of plants
because their existence is just that
remarkable
land is a stressful place to settle down
on
especially for an algae that is making
its way out of water it would have had
to contend with so much more sun than
before unfiltered and unrefracted by
water
and that would put the algae at risk for
damage to its cell and its dna
on top of that
land is dry
it's easy to take water for granted when
you live in a pond or an ocean
but land makes you even more dependent
on the weather to provide moisture and
on the morsels of water you can gather
from your environment
so whatever algae made its way onto land
it had to have contained incredible
potential
an enormous capacity to contend with the
stresses of an environment that was
fundamentally different
from the home it was leaving
while we don't know exactly what that
potential looked like scientists do have
some theories
one idea is that this mysterious
ancestral algae
may have been able to cheat a little
that it was somewhat predisposed to life
on land
because maybe it originally lived in
fresh water
where conditions are just a little
closer to land compared to marine
habitats
it could also be that streptophyte algae
just got here first but maybe it beat
other algae to the punch
and that because it was first it had
very little competition as it adapted to
the new challenges it was facing it
could thrive without having to struggle
for space or resources
taking over the land and developing new
structures that would give it an
advantage over any other algae that
tried to come onto land later
those are a few general theories about
what might have enabled the streptophyte
algae to adapt readily to land
but scientists also wonder about the
specifics
the details of the algae's appearance
that would have morphed into the traits
that allowed embryophytes to dominate
land
and with the genetic tools available
today
scientists have made progress
on understanding more of this mysterious
past
they've identified the closest living
relative to land plants
a group of streptophyte algae called
zignamitals that include this spirogyra
and scientists have used this
relationship to form new hypotheses
around ancient family traits
plus there are many many many plants in
the world whose present day forms reveal
the messy web that evolution has spun
take for example the stomata
you can see them here
the microscopic openings that help the
plant take in carbon dioxide and release
water
the stomata is the kind of adaptation
that is key to plant survival on land
creating many tiny valves that tune the
plant's interior
to best match whatever the changing
world around it demands
scientists have even found stem
model-like openings on plant fossils
dating back more than 400 million years
ago
not all modern-day plants have stomata
though including some bryophytes like
liverworts
so scientists had to dive into the
phylogenetic history woven into plant
dna
to figure out that the first land plants
likely did have stomata
and that bryophytes may have reduced
their stomata over time
to the point that some even lost their
stomata entirely
it's all a bit like looking at your
family members today to try and figure
out whether an ancestor millions of
years ago
had dimples
the results are a clue into one small
feature of an ancient algae that made
its way onto land
a sign that it may have had its own
ancestral form of a stomata
and if that's the case
then perhaps an ancient bryophyte
inherited that stomata
only to eventually lose it through many
cycles of change and selection
it would hardly be the first plant to
take its inheritance from that
remarkable algae
and then decide to do away with it
these cells belong to aegeria densa
you may have seen it before
it's the plant commonly found in
aquariums
and yet this is an embryophyte a member
of the land plants
it just
happened to have found its way back into
the water
leaving behind the land that its unknown
ancestor once conquered
it can be difficult to piece together
why anything in evolution
happens the way it happens
it's easy with hundreds of millions of
years of hindsight
to describe these events with some sort
of inevitability
after all
we live in a world covered in plants
we live because of a world covered in
plants
to conceive of our world without plants
would be to conceive of a world without
us as we are today
but
maybe the point of all this
is that hindsight is a convenient story
we tell ourselves
and that none of this was inevitable
an algae came onto land
and it changed the world
the rest as they say
is history
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us
and thank you again to ren for
sponsoring this episode of journey to
the micro microcosmos
ren is a website where you can calculate
your carbon emissions then offset it by
funding projects like providing clean
burning fuel and cook stoves to refugees
in uganda or a project that uses
satellite monitoring and drones to
detect deforestation in the amazon
rainforest we'll need a lot of different
approaches to stop the climate crisis
and this is one way that you can learn
more about your carbon contribution and
take some action you'll answer a few
questions about your lifestyle and
they'll also show you ways you can start
reducing your carbon emissions
no one can reduce their footprint to
zero but using ren you can help offset
what you have left once you sign up
you'll receive updates from the tree
planting rainforest protection and other
projects you support and we've partnered
with ren to plant 10 additional trees
for the first 100 people who sign up
using our link in the description
before we go we'd also like to say thank
you to each and every one of our patrons
some of their names are on the screen
right now
and these are the people that make this
channel and videos like this possible
and we are so grateful
if you'd like to become one of them you
can go to patreon.com
journey to micro
if you'd like to see more from our
master of microscopes james weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
instagram
and if you'd like to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you